when you're building something new
there's going to be mistakes and it's
important to to recognize those mistakes
acknowledge them and take corrective
action yeah and the success of a company
is very much more about how quick are
you to fix the mistakes not will you
make mistakes the difference between a
startup that is successful in one that
is not and it's because they both made
mistakes but the successful one
recognize the mistakes fix them very
quickly and the the unsuccessful one
tries to deny that the mistakes exist in
physics you're taught to always question
yourself you're taught to always assume
that you're wrong not to assume that
you're right and you have to prove
yourself not not wrong and so I think
that that that physics framework is
really where where I learnt it and it's
very effective for and it for learning
counterintuitive things that aren't
obvious it's not like I like failure and
you're like failure was terrible but if
you only do things that are certain to
succeed then you're only gonna be doing
a very obvious thing that third failure
in a row did you think I need to pack
this in never why not I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or hopefully
being faster you just watched two
amazing clip some Elon Musk take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how to apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]